영국은 전쟁 중인 나라가 아닙니다.
화폐가 무너진 것도 아니고, 식량난이 벌어진 것도 아닙니다.
국가 시스템이 하루아침에 붕괴된 것도 아닙니다.
여전히 런던은 세계적인 금융 도시이고,
명문대학도 있고, 글로벌 기업도 있고,
오랜 제도와 문화도 있습니다.
그런데 이상한 일이 벌어지고 있습니다.
젊은 사람들이 영국을 떠나고 있습니다.
영국 통계청 ONS에 따르면
2025년 6월까지 1년 동안 영국을 장기적으로 떠난 사람은
약 69만 3천 명이었습니다.
이 숫자는 영국 국적자만이 아니라
영국에 살던 외국인까지 포함한 전체 장기 이탈자입니다.
그중 영국 국적자는 약 25만 2천 명이었고,
영국은 2025년 3월 기준 영국 국적 이탈자의
약 76%가 35세 미만이었다고 정리했습니다.
이들이 떠나는 이유는 거창하지 않습니다.
집은 너무 비싸고, 월급은 충분히 늘지 않고,
세금 부담은 커지고, 병원은 오래 기다려야 하고,
앞으로 나아질 것이라는 확신이 약해졌기 때문입니다.
그런데 이 장면이 이상하게 낯설지가 않습니다.
영국 이야기를 하고 있는데, 자꾸 한국이 떠오릅니다.
서울의 집값, 청년의 주거 불안, 월급보다 빠르게 오른 생활비,
결혼과 출산을 미루는 세대, 그리고 이런 질문입니다.
열심히 살아도 내 삶이 나아질 수 있을까?
오늘 우리가 주목할 이야기는 바로 이 질문입니다.
한때 산업혁명의 발상지였고, 세계 금융의 중심이었던 영국은
왜 청년들이 떠나고 싶은 나라가 되었을까요?
그리고 왜 이 이야기는,
한국에서도 남의 일처럼 들리지 않을까요?
영국의 문제는 단순히 돈이 없다는 것이 아닙니다.
더 정확히는 돈을 벌어낼 경제의 힘이 약해졌다는 데 있습니다.
2008년 글로벌 금융위기 이후 영국 경제는 이전의 성장 흐름으로 돌아가지 못했습니다.
생산성 성장은 약해졌고, 기업 투자도 충분히 늘지 않았습니다.
영국 생산성 연구기관은 2025년 2분기 기준,
영국의 시간당 생산성이 팬데믹 이전보다 겨우 1.5% 높은 수준이었고,
전년 같은 기간보다,
0.8% 낮아졌다고 분석했습니다.
생산성은 어렵게 말할 필요가 없습니다.
같은 1시간을 일했을 때, 얼마나 많은 가치를 만들어내는가입니다.
영국 사람들이 갑자기 게을러진 것이 아닙니다.
문제는 더 많은 가치를 만들기 어려운 경제 환경이 오래 누적됐다는 점입니다.
낡은 인프라, 부족한 투자, 약한 직업 훈련, 느린 행정이 겹치면,
사람들은 열심히 일해도 예전만큼 빠르게 소득을 늘리기 어렵습니다.
그 출발점에,
2010년대,
2008년 금융위기 이후 영국 정부는 재정적자를 줄이고 빚을 관리하기 위해 지출을 줄였습니다.
겉으로는 책임 있는 선택처럼 보였습니다.
하지만 실제로 줄이는 것은 단순한 낭비만이 아니었습니다.
인프라, 연구개발, 직업훈련, 성인교육, 지역산업 기반처럼 장기성장에 필요한 투자도 함께 약해졌습니다.
여기서 중요한 것은 긴축 자체가 언제나 틀렸다는 뜻은 아닙니다.
문제는 무엇을 줄였느냐입니다.
낭비를 줄이는 것은 필요합니다.
하지만,
미래의 생산성을 높이는 투자까지 줄이면 단기적으로는 돈을 아끼는 것처럼 보여도 장기적으로는 돈을 벌어낸 능력이 약해집니다.
그리고 2016년에 브렉시트가 있었죠.
여기서 의심은 이 결정이 투자와 무역, 노동시장에 어떤 영향을 줬느냐입니다.
기업은 장기 투자를 할 때 규칙을 봅니다.
그런데 브렉시트 이후 영국 기업들은 EU와 어떤 조건으로 거래를 할지, 관세와 규제는 어떻게 될지, 인력은 어떻게 확보할지에 대해 불확실성을 겪었습니다.
영국 재정감시기구 OBR은 브렉시트로 장기적으로 영국의 무역 강도가 15% 낮아졌고 잠재생산성이 4% 낮아질 것으로 추정했습니다.
2025년 NBER 연구도 브렉시트 과정이 2025년까지 영국 GDP를 6-8%, 투자를 12-18%, 생산성을 3-4% 낮췄다고 추정했습니다.
브렉시트 직후 영국 경제가 바로 무너진 것은 아닙니다.
하지만 투자가 줄면 생산성이 낮아지고 생산성이 낮아지면
인근과 세수도 약해집니다.
그러면 공공서비스를 고칠 돈도 부족해지겠죠.
이 흐름이 오래 이어지면 겉으로는 선진국처럼 보여도 안에서는 여력이 줄어듭니다.
그리고 이 지점에서 주택 문제가 등장합니다.
영국은 오랫동안 집값 상승을 성공처럼 받아들였습니다.
하지만 집값 상승은 모두에게 같은 의미가 아닙니다.
이미 집을 가진 사람에게는 자산 상승이지만 집이 없는 청년에게는 진입장벽입니다.
2025년 기준
중간 주택가격은 30만 파운드였습니다.
풀타임 노동자의 중간 연소득 39,300파운드의 7.6배입니다.
런던은 평균 주택가격이 평균 소득의 10.5배였고
켄싱턴 & 첼시는 25.2배였습니다.
영국 통계청은 주택가격이 소득의 5배를 넘으면
넓은 의미에서 부담 가능한 수준을 넘어선 것으로 봅니다.
주택 공급을 늘리면 가격은 안정될 수 있습니다.
하지만 기존 주택 소유자의 자산가치가 흔들릴 수 있겠죠.
그리고 이들은 대체로 투표율이 높습니다.
그래서 정치는 주택 문제를 말하면서도
집값 하락을 두려워합니다.
그 결과 청년은 월급을 모아 자산을 쌓기보다
높은 주거비를 감당하는데 많은 힘을 쓰게 됩니다.
그 다음 문제는 세금입니다.
영국 정부는 코로나와 에너지 위기를 거치면서
막대한 돈을 썼습니다.
이후 우크라이나 전쟁으로 에너지 가격이 급등했고
가계와 기업을 지원하기 위한 지출도 늘었습니다.
문제는 그 다음입니다.
금리가 오르자 정부가 이미 진 빚에 대한
이자 비용이 크게 늘었습니다.
ONS에 따르면
2025년 11월 말 영국의 공공부문 순부채는
GDP의 95.6%로 1960년대 초 이후 높은 수준이었습니다.
2024년과 2025년 회계연도 순부채 이자 지출은
1,060억 파운드 GDP의 3.6%
정부 지출의 8.2%였습니다.
이러면 정부의 선택지가 좁아집니다.
의료, 주택, 인프라, 교육에 모두 돈이 필요합니다.
그런데 이미 빚과 이자 부담이 큽니다.
더 빌리기도 어렵고 세금을 올리기도 부담스럽습니다.
그래서 나타난 것이 수문 증세입니다.
대표적인 것이 피스컬 드래그이죠.
쉽게 말하면 세금 기준선을 그대로 둬서
사람들이 자연스럽게 더 많은 세금을 내게 되는 구조입니다.
임금이 물가 때문에 조금 올랐는데
세금을 내기 시작하는 기준이나 높은 세율이 적용되는 기준은
그대로라면 어떻게 될까요?
실질적으로 더 부자가 된 것도 아닌데
더 높은 세율 구간에 들어갈 수 있습니다.
월급은 오른 것 같은데
손에 남는 돈은 생각보다 늘지 않는 이유가 여기에 있는 겁니다.
여기에 추가로 의료 문제가 겹칩니다.
NHS는 National Health Service, 즉 영국의 국가보건서비스입니다.
세금으로 운영되는 공공의료체계입니다.
진료비 부담은 낮지만
검사나 수술을 오래 기다리는 문제가 자주 발생합니다.
그래서 NHS 대기자 수는 단순한 의료통계가 아닙니다.
사람들이 제때 치료를 받고 다시 일터로 돌아갈 수 있는지를 보는
노동시장 지표이기도 합니다.
치료가 늦어지면 일을 줄이거나
그만두는 사람이 생깁니다.
그러면 소득과 세금은 줄고
복지지출은 늘 수 있습니다.
청년이 나라를 떠난다는 것은 단순한 인구이동이 아닙니다.
미래의 세금, 소비, 창업, 기술, 출산 가능성이 함께 빠져나가는 일입니다.
떠날 수 있는 청년은 대체로 이동성이 높습니다.
반대로 취약한 청년은 국내에 남아도 교육과 고용에서 밀려날 수 있습니다.
한쪽에서는 인재가 빠져나가고
다른 한쪽에서는 청년이 노동시장에 들어오지 못하고 있는 겁니다.
그렇다면 왜 영국 정치는 이 문제를 고치지 못했을까요?
문제를 몰라서만은 아닙니다.
집을 더 지어야 한다는 것도 알고
생산성 투자가 필요하다는 것도 알고
의료를 고쳐야 한다는 것도 압니다.
하지만 선거는 장기개혁을 쉽게 보상하지 않습니다.
주택공급은 기존 주택 소유자의 반발을 부를 수 있습니다.
연금개혁은 고령층의 반발을 부릅니다.
인프라와 교육투자는 성과가 늦게 나옵니다.
영국 국가연금에는 트리플 낙이 있습니다.
물가상승률, 임금상승률,
2.5% 중 가장 높은 기준으로 매년 연금을 올리는 방식입니다.
노인빈곤을 막는 취지는 있지만
고령화와 저성장이 겹치면 재정부담이 커집니다.
이 대봉에서 다시 한국을 생각하게 됩니다.
한국과 영국은 다릅니다.
산업도, 의료도, 정치도 다릅니다.
하지만 닮은 질문이 있습니다.
집값은 누구를 위해 존재하는가?
정치는 누구의 미래를 먼저 보호하는가?
청년은 노력하면 나아질 수 있다고 믿는가?
국가는 미래세대에게 아직 설득력 있는 약속을
줄 수 있는가?
국가의 위기는 꼭 국채를 갚지 못하는 순간에만 오는 것이 아닙니다.
젊은 세대가 그 나라의 미래를 더 이상 믿지 않는 순간
위기는 이미 조용히 시작됐을 수 있습니다.
영국의 위기를 보며 한국이 떠오르는 이유도 바로 여기에 있는 겁니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.